idioms crop up
that people often use unthinkingly
this guy is using the idiom Uncle Tom
unthinkingly he doesn't know what it
means but that that happens for a lot of
us all the time
let there be light forbidden fruit am I
My Brother's Keeper fire and brimstone
the blind leading the blind go the extra
mile all of those idioms come from the
Bible most people don't know that they
come from the Bible
in in fact many people who have never
read the Bible who don't believe in the
Bible will use those idioms all the time
that's that's how culture works culture
works by certain texts by certain pieces
of art by certain rituals just creeping
in and not only becoming not only being
inserted into your language but actually
coming to constitute your language and
by constituting your language it
constitutes the way that you think